hey everyone Perry here with another
Collider Sundance interview for you
brought to you by the Kia Telluride a
huge thanks to them for making this all
happen because it means we could talk
about top and wedding right now welcome
thank you for your time today
welcome to Sundance and Park City
because I hear all of you just arrived
yes I arrived yesterday and I've never
been in this amount of snow before I
fell in the snow yesterday we were just
talking about the hidden black ice on
the sidewalks everywhere so I totally
understand did anybody give any of you
guys some Sundance tips and tricks
before you came here warm clothes
ultimately because like all the ski
slopes are empty which I thought would
be I thought it'd be in the opposite the
ski slopes would be busy because of the
festival put there in two I'm kind of
jealous you guys are here I'm so excited
to tell everybody about your movie but I
figured of all people I should leave it
to you do you want to briefly give us an
OPS s of the movie for all of our
viewers who do not know what top end
wedding is so top end wedding is
essentially a really romantic funny
story
set up in the Northern Territory the
bride and groom to be of the story I end
up in the Northern Territory because
they have 10 days to get married and
when you're writing the script
co-writing the script do you write this
role with yourself in mind are you kind
of tailoring it to yourself um yes
that's what Josh Tyler and I my
co-writer always had in mind and because
I think that the thing that struck him
was that how much he loved the Northern
Territory where I grew up and and we
talked about all the romantic comedies
that we watched and we were real nerds
about it so that's how he came up we
came up with the
it's a cool thing to be able to kind of
spearhead an opportunity for yourself
too rather than wait around for things
you just have an idea and you make it
happen yes definitely it was it's the
kind of it's the kind of film I always
wanted to say it was the kind of film I
always hoped young Aboriginal women in
the Northern Territory and across
Australia to see and to bring it to like
an international level it's just like
Sundance nonetheless to kick it all off
wane how'd you get involved here did the
script come your way and what kind of
sparked you to the idea of knowing that
you needed to direct this movie well I
work with Miranda and a film called the
sapphires which we did five or six years
ago and so we had a connection and I
think we've known each other for a while
and Sydney it's a small world a small
city in some respects but yeah and then
the script came my way responded to it
and as Miranda sort of said you know
just see a film in the Northern
Territory done this way kakadu darwin
katherine and then we go to this place
called the Tiwi islands you know to
introduce that to the world was sort of
something special
sort of had a bit of a meaning to it and
yeah it was just sort of just a just to
just to get into a script like this was
was fantastic for me not a bad place to
be working how familiar were you with
this region was all of this kind of new
to you not at all no I mean III been to
Australia and I'd been to let Western
Australia and Sydney but I'd never been
to the Northern Territory I suppose my
only understanding of it and watching
Crocodile Dundee it's like not a really
true understanding of the Northern
Territory but I remember reading the
script and just being immediately just I
fell in love with it really because it's
a beautiful romantic comedy but also
that idea of people connecting with
their roots and their heritage is
something really sung to me and so from
that point on I started googling like
these places like katherine gorge and
kakadu and the TV islands and i might
get me and i want to be in this film
because if you have to see the landscape
is like nothing I've ever seen before
I've actually seen a couple of films
here this year that are about merging
cultures and just introducing people to
someone else with a different background
so it was
an important thing to be able to
highlight here absolutely and there
really I mean while the sapphires was a
very funny
joyous film I think what what was what
was really tough for me was that there
was really not a lot for me to reference
so I had to kind of watch like all the
romantic comedies that were made in the
UK in the US and then try and find some
sort of understanding with that I had to
I said because I sort of had to say okay
well where how would I how do I shift
the gaze and and and I sort of had to
really just trust that I was being
honest and authentic and I was telling
it in the right way I'm so curious what
movies were you looking at so of course
there was My Big Fat Greek Wedding yes
Four Weddings and a funeral my best
friend's wedding all of them with
wedding I watched every single one that
had that in their title but also you
know I was watching what was so great
was that around the time Josh and I were
writing the film the big Sikh had just
come out and the incredible Jessica
James so you know I was really grateful
to see that like people were really
experimenting with the genre and talking
about okay well how do I see the world
differently or under is an expert in
just a reference book of romantic
comedies it's excellent we do a show on
Collider it's a trivia show and we
should totally have like a romantic
comedy slice on the wheel or a wedding
movies land just for you and then you
should come and play I wish I knew more
questions off the top of my head so you
have a gigantic ensemble in this movie
you two are the anchors for it but I was
wondering if you could give a shout out
to maybe your favorite smaller
performance that isn't in the spotlight
so much because everybody kind of has a
memorable role to play in their journey
they do what about the UM truck driver
the truck driver
a little no no you don't matter anyway
we have some like amazing we t8 adapt
ISM chicken s'en made your father yes
fantastic Carrie Fox who was awesome
yeah she absolutely is and of course the
the three actors that played the
bridesmaids just yet that so not only
are they my friends but they are just
the most funniest women that I know why
should get to when you guys all interact
you can see there's some genuine
chemistry yeah that's what we're like in
in real life yes so and Shari was in the
sapphires as well so yeah I'm so glad
that we could have her back on it I
didn't have it I didn't have a huge
amount to do when I did it was like a
battle to go you're gonna give your
canine co-star a little shout-out well
yeah fly fly fly that was yes Lea fly
I'll find any reason to bring up a pet
in an interview even if it's not in the
movie I will just ask why didn't this
person have a pet those dogs those dogs
have a good life they don't fly because
the air on the airplanes is not good for
their respiratory systems to dry so we
started out filming in Adelaide which is
the very bottom of our journey and
finished off in Darwin and we all flew
up then it's like five six hour flight
you go right across the country these
dogs drove for five days to get to
Darwin good for them hard workers right
there so again big ensemble here and it
feels like every single character goes
there's some sort of growing experience
where they're dealing with personal
hardships and one of my favorite lines
in the move
is when someone says when you're when
you're hurt and where do you go looking
so I wanted to pose that question to the
three of you when you need a little help
in life who do you turn to and why well
I mean I'm just gonna rip off the film
and say my mum or my family you know
that's always my kind of safe space to
go to I'm really lucky that I was raised
by a whole group of people to raise a
child well a village literally raised me
so I'm so and I think I I think I heard
LeBron say that you know when you get
when you get a sort of platform that you
bring your you end up bringing your
whole community like because they're the
ones that shaped you mold you molded you
and made you the person that you were so
that was this is this is why the film is
so important to me
this is why it is a love letter because
I would not have made it when I was I
moved to Sydney when I was 18 years old
I had no idea what I was doing and when
I was lost when when everyone told me I
needed to figure it out on my own when I
come back to the territory I'd resent to
myself I ground myself and I go okay I'm
ready to take on the big city again I
can I can make this dream of mine come
true can totally understand where you're
coming from with that bye home home so
you just click your heels three times or
Italian shoes or what have you you know
what I mean just do that and then you
get home so home is the thing that's
sort of his constant right there with
you guys but there are a lot of crazy
funny silly moments in this movie so I
was wondering of everything that we see
from a comedy perspective what was the
most difficult to nail and kind of not
lose control in your own humor in the
moment and crack up so so we had a weed
this scene where without spoiling it too
much where we've asked
we've asked where the mummies were
Lauren's mummies and the dad Trevor just
turns away and like goes into the pantry
and and hides and and in plays Chicago's
if you leave me now
and I was I've always found that thing
really funny but I think it was Gwilym
look at me like myth confusion like when
he was playing Ned he just went and I I
just really it took everything for me to
just not it was nothing was said it was
just he plays it be he really plays it
for like trapped for a tragic moment
he's I he's a broken man isn't he oh but
in that is so much but also he can cry
on cue it's just ridiculous but we've
all been there in a breakup you know
what I mean we sort of pull from that
metaphorically yeah yeah yeah
actually that kind of segue is perfectly
to a game I want to play with you guys
so we play would you rather on collider
they're all filmmaking questions and
I've also mixed in some Sundance
questions right now but piggybacking off
of what you just said a question for the
two of you would you rather have to
laugh or cry in a scene that's a good
question
obviously there there is a there is a
cathodic thing to crying but no I just
feel like I'm always tired after a scene
where I've been crying all day I'd say
I'd say laugh as well I mean like it's
it can be a bit maniacal when you don't
feel that something's funny but
fortunately with this film everything
made us laugh so easily it was a quite
genuine you know laughter when it
happens so it was easy but when you have
to force it it's pretty good send you a
yeah Wayne would you rather screen test
your movies or go with your gut
test your movie so go if you got I go
with my god yeah I put inflection but uh
yeah in what when what sense I have to
you when you test the movie in front of
audiences and then get your feedback and
then apply it to what you did look it's
a little bit of both but I'm gonna be
hard on my yep got to a certain degree
right you can have a balance between the
two I know is a little bit of both would
you rather walk around Sundance with wet
boots or no gloves I've got terrible
circulation so I'd have to take the
gloves
yeah I'm right there with my hands
turned white within seconds of me being
outside yeah yeah I I have had wet boots
though the snow got into just the gaps
and that was yeah I I was I was
shivering because it just it just the
cold just traveled up through my body so
I don't know and my hands do get cold
but yeah I've never experienced cold
like that
you're warm hearted when you go through
the territory it's like it's hot yeah
it's hot absolutely yes this is extreme
but for you guys in particular I'm
excited to ask this would you rather go
to a film festival with a crowd pleaser
or a more challenging film because after
seeing this I have an answer to that but
I need to pose it to you guys oh that is
that is for me that that's really
difficult now that I've gone into
screenwriting because obviously as an
indigenous woman of Australia you know
it is it is it can be really contentious
to to kind of speak upon the issues that
affect a lot of Indigenous Australians
and so which is why I wanted to make a
crowd-pleaser because I wanted people to
maybe take a step back and show them why
this community is so special why they
why the wider mainstream community
should care why they should even up the
playing field and also
you know six see them as human and so
sometimes I with hard-hitting films in
Australia sometimes it can just be too
confronting for people and that's one of
the biggest things a lot of people have
gone oh my goodness we're so glad that
top end weddings come out because we
just want something joyous but I always
believe that there should be space for
both absolutely it depends on the
festival but Sundance 2019 a
crowd-pleaser I stated the world at the
moment like the politics in this country
the politics our country glulams country
hello you know that triangle of love so
2019 a crowd-pleaser tapped into exactly
what was going through my mind right now
I have to wrap this up but a huge thank
you for being here with us today another
thank you to Kia Telluride for making
this happen guys like and share this
video also keep an eye out for top then
wedding more Sundance 2019 coverage
coming your way real soon
you